And there's an example
in the textbook content for this lesson that you can
check out if you're interested.
In short, we can always divide the systems into two separate collections, the ones that are measured
and the ones that aren't.
And once we've done that, we fall back on the method
method that I've just described, and that's how measurements for multiple quantum systems work.
And now finally, we move on to unitary
operations on multiple systems.
Using the same basic idea that multiple systems can be viewed as single compound systems.
We conclude what you see
written here on the screen, quantum operations on compound systems are represented by unitary matrices
just like we have for single systems and specifically the rows and columns of those unitary matrices correspond to the Cartesian product
of the classical state sets of whatever collection of
systems we're talking about.
For example, if we have a system X
whose classical states are one, two, and three and Y is a Qubit,
then the matrix that you see right here is an example of a unitary matrix that represents an
operation on the pair XY.
The details of how we
order Cartesian products that we talked about before don't really matter for
the sake of this example, it's just a six by six matrix
that happens to be unitary.
There's nothing special about it, although it is built out of a
couple of important matrices.
The point is that you could
choose any six by six unitary matrix and it would represent
a unitary operation on XY.
If we apply a collection of
unitary operations independently each on its own system, then the action of them all together
on the compound system is
given by the tensor product.
And here on the screen you can see a more precise
statement of that fact.
If our unitary operations are described by the unitary matrices U1 through Un one for each of our systems,
then the combined action
on the compound system is given by the tensor
product of U1 up to Un.
Once again, similar to what we had in the probabilistic setting, an important example is that
we apply some unitary operation
U to a system X and we do
nothing to some other system Y.
The operation on XY that we get is U tensored with the identity matrix.
The identity matrix
describes doing nothing to Y.
Sometimes it's helpful to write explicitly that this identity matrix
corresponds to the system Y, just to make the formulas more clear.
And one option is to
give the identity matrix a subscript like this that indicates the system that it acts upon.
When it's clear enough, though we usually don't
bother with a subscript, but when things get more complicated, it can be very helpful.
And we can also consider
the symmetric case where some unitary
operation V is applied to Y and nothing is done to X,
and this time the resulting
unitary operation on XY, is represented by this
tensor product here.
And once again, we can put a subscript on the
identity matrix if it helps.
Here are a couple of specific examples.
If X and Y are Qubits and we
perform a Hadamard operation on X and we do nothing to Y, we get the matrix that you see right here.
If on the other hand, we perform the Hadamard operation on Y and we do nothing to X, the ordering of the tensor
product is reversed.
And so we get the matrix
that you see right here.
Not every unitary operation
on a compound system can be expressed as a tensor product.
If we have a tensor product,
then we have independence.
And there are some pretty
fundamental examples of operations that certainly
don't act independently on multiple systems.
For example, if X and Y have
the same classical state set, which could be any
classical state set sigma,
then we can think about the
swap operation on the pair XY.
This operation doesn't change the ordering of the two systems, we still have X in the
left and Y on the right, but rather it represents
swapping the contents
of the two systems. Here you can see that expressed
in the form of an equation where we have a tensor
product of two quantum states.
Another way to write it is as
a matrix as we see right here.
The way you can think
about this description is that it tells you what happens for standard basis vectors.
And once we know what happens
for standard basis vectors, we know what happens for
arbitrary quantum states by linearity,
which in fact is also true for
this expression right here.
So this particular operation right here happens to be a deterministic operation as well as a unitary operation.
If X and Y are Qubits, for instance, we get this matrix
representation right here.
Here's an interesting connection
between the swap operation and the four Bell states, which are shown right
here for convenience.
The swap operation leaves the
first three of them alone, but it puts a minus sign in
front of the Psi minus state,